les jardiniers du château de françois
1er son talent ouvrage les bruits du
jardin italiennes sont prêts et pendant
que monsieur robot s'occupe des pelouse
les humains près par les décorations
intérieures ont fait des efforts et pour
noël mais c'est juste et décorations de
noël et on fait des forêts avec des
bouleaux et des sports ça fait plaisir
surtout aussi que les jambes lourdes et
décorations de noël c'est quand même
plus sympa de venir ici que de rester
chez soi à broyer du noir
les châteaux de la loire ont reçu
l'autorisation d'accueillir à nouveau du
public à partir du 15 décembre
alors il n'y a pas de temps à perdre il
faut préparer les salles pour donner à
rêver aux visiteurs cette année c'était
un peu compliqué normalement devrait
pouvoir accueillir les premiers
visiteurs le 19 décembre exactement dans
la salle du conseil il a fallu une
semaine à deux pour installer la crèche
napolitaine traditionnelle et ses 50
personnages à côté de marie josèphe les
rois mages on trouve les marchands des
rues de naples et les commerces ouverts
comme une coïncidence
aussi j'ai encore eu encore une dizaine
de jours de boulot en sachant qu'on
travaille au chômage partiel quand on
est on est trois jours par semaine que
je pense qu'on va augmenter les on va
augmenter les les jours parce que ça va
être trop juste là
la féerie de noël devrait s'installer
partout ambiance recueillie en vert et
blanc dans la chapelle saint-hubert près
du tombeau de léonard de vinci au
château la réouverture est une bonne
nouvelle
ce qui nous rapproche la normale bien
nous remplit de joueurs et on fait ce
métier en plus pour rencontrer les gens
donc c'est vraiment l'essence de notre
caractère et on retrouve là justement le
moyen de s'épanouir
les responsables attendent maintenant
les nouvelles règles sanitaires pour
adapter les espaces le château doit
fermer plus tard
de nuit à la lumière des bougies